I compare Carmita hmmm a every [ __ ]
day how so my calmly changed since I
became a fan of mmm-hmm because there's
so many aspects that go into hmmm a the
same way of so many aspects that go into
comedy let's take the elephant out of
the room I've always loved you
yeah I've always loved you have had a
great respect for you get punched in the
[ __ ] head now a lot of people could
get punched in the head you decided one
day you didn't want to do this you
didn't want to fight no more you didn't
see the you didn't see it anymore you
didn't have what you had when you first
started you know sometimes people look
behind the curtain or something and it
changes you know you know I hate this
the businesses fandom I [ __ ] hate the
businesses stand up I hate the business
to stand up but I love standing up yeah
from corner so I figured out how to
avoid all those things that our own life
and stand-up comedy that he goes and
stuff like that you got out of it you
started a podcast it became very
successful one day I'm going through
[ __ ] Facebook and I see that [ __ ]
Brendan Schaub 'he's doing stand-up at
the store and I don't know
I go why's he doing this I don't want
him you know in my heart I'm like and I
wasn't hating no but yeah I just didn't
know what you were gonna go up there and
talk protective man yeah I avoided you
yeah you did I didn't say a [ __ ] word
I can't I don't want to be put in the
position with Brendan comes up to me and
asked me what do I think like he's my
brother the other day I [ __ ] you know
are he's gone so I called Eric and I go
Eric do you mind if I host Ari wrote me
a letter and he goes I want you to watch
and you know so the other night when I
went to that storytelling show this is
what this is not happening
I was sitting there as Joey Diaz but in
my mind I was Ari and I would go up to
Harvey afterward and go what do you
think of that story and he dumped he's
talking about this that's not a story
that's a bit you know I like them very
little cold to me even when I came in oh
yeah I was I knew so I even I thinks
Rogan and Bryan I'm like dude did I do
something to Joey before this like weeks
before though goddammit
listen you're a fighter you've had dirty
fights you son stays oh I've had a bunch
yeah 35 yeah okay amateur but what if
tomorrow I got my blue belt and you were
happy for me and then two weeks later
you saw a picture of me on Twitter at
the boxing gym on Sunset my fat little
guy and all sudden a month later you saw
Joey
going to a smoker yeah and for some
reason Joey goes five and all yeah he
armbars one guy no more ISM with his way
the other guy was a lucky punch you know
what those smokers not everybody's yeah
ready friend my man I'm better I go five
or no one day I bump into you and I got
the balls to tell you bro I'm quitting
stand up I talked to Dana he's gonna
give me a fight against you're gonna
look at me and go Jesus Joey you're a
good stand-up why you doing this I get
it man so when all this is going down
I'm like why is this happening I like
him on the podcast I'm sitting there and
you went on stage and more and more
every [ __ ] two minutes I fell in love
with you more I thought you only go up
then tell a story about UFC [ __ ] and
[ __ ] protein stinky [ __ ] or
something it was completely different
you told a [ __ ] very touching story
of your heart and what your goals were
and you had it set up
you had the tags at the perfect place
you talked about you know things that
I've always laughed about like this is
why I don't go to sport games because
you've got to walk in with a Jersey what
if that team loses you gotta take the
train all the way home in New York with
a met shirt on like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah people don't think about oh I can't
imagine being on the losing end of a
fight and walking out holding your stuff
they never even show it only once when I
lost Dana White made sure that camera
was an outdoor they had them in the
bathroom crying humiliated it's
humiliating it's [ __ ] humiliate you
describe it and you put me there mm-hmm
like I was like oh my god you know I
could never [ __ ] do this what he did
and you went and I left there that might
blown away like I went home and sadly
what I said
talent is talent I'm such an [ __ ] for
thinking that I thought I've had a lot
of people have just gotten into stand
and then after they done it a year then
actually come up to me and poke their
chest up to me like said like bro I'm
going to Montreal and it took me a year
and in my mind I won't wish him no evil
but I'll go this [ __ ]
yeah has no idea he has no idea he's
gonna go up there and bomb when he sees
the big lights it's like fighting and
smokers for sure then I'm in Vegas [ __ ]
and even though I'm five and oh and I
got a great right hand different and I
got a great jujitsu game my guard is
tight let me tell you something the
lights the people that's a completely
different ballgame you know I'm gonna
[ __ ] my pants at The Wiltern theater
I've been doing comedy 26 [ __ ] years I
went out to the Walton Peter I looked up
I saw those people I had to stop the two
seconds broke my legs went out from
under me I'm saying so when you did that
the other night I went home and I slept
a couple hours and I woke you
I called you right in the mall he did
and I go dog what I saw last night blew
me away gave me hope yeah man because
you told the story you know how he has a
big problem between a bit and the story
there's a big difference with a bit and
a [ __ ] storm big difference big
difference and you saw it that night a
[ __ ] great you could do a bit and it's
great and it's probably true what you're
telling me it's probably two but it's
not a story this condon tations and your
voice and different things in the story
and you have to take me I have to see
you yeah man you made me saw you on the
floor I almost fainted thinking about
the booger and the red blood all on the
floor while you would go robbery
so you took me for a psychological
journey and that psychological journey
was so good that it made me drive to
Playa del Rey to see my brother yeah and
give them props man the [ __ ] I mean
that from my heart so I just want to
know menthol in correlation for you what
if at 35 I got a blue belt and all of a
sudden I'm walking around with Tapout
deer and you're like oh he doesn't know
no in and I get 100% and I've seen a
thick skin to it and I expect it to be
honest even you know with rogue and you
eat Karen D'Elia wrote Mike hit it man I
get it and that there's a you know I I
don't know what to say I was talking
last night with the owner of the Comedy
Store
just man you sold out La Joya already in
it I yeah I have no business doing that
I'm glad I did have no business you're
putting out a good product
but I got to go back to the story here
seven years ago Rogan taped a special
somewhere and Dana White was there it
was like a Friday night before a UFC and
I was on stage trying to be cute I
wasn't really in those days I would just
snort coke and I would think about what
am I going to say tonight like I didn't
put no effort while it was a kid up
there and when it was a 50-50 I was just
a funny guy that would take a 50-50 shot
but I was on stage doing my thing and
the only thing I can see from stage with
that which I never look at the audience
was I saw Brendan Shaw I'm in like row
11 and I didn't know you then I think
you had just finished the Ultimate
Fighter you were about to fight but you
weren't fighting that weekend and I
looked at your face
and you had a face you weren't laughing
and you weren't disgusted with me you
just had a different look on and that
night on the drive home it came back to
me what that look on your face was you
were figuring it out and I went to watch
you again when you were watching Rogan
you were enthralled with it something
was captivating you and that made me
think back to that night what you were
watching that night you were watching us
going wow that's pretty [ __ ] up but
they do the same way when I watch you
getting in against somebody I go that's
pretty [ __ ] up when they do these are
both arts yep I don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody tells you yep MMA and stand up a
both [ __ ] arts man I consider you an
artist just like me and MMA when when
you fight five or six times and I see
the breakdown and it's Brendan going
well you know I'm not worried about his
jujitsu game because my hand is right
here that guy's going to lose because he
didn't evolve between training camps
yeah he didn't go to a Muay Thai place
and go let me just learn Muay Thai you
know even if I take just take a kick out
and learn how to distance my head I
won't be getting clip these guys don't
grow mm-hmm
so from watching
I learned what I had to do to grow in
between training camps you always got to
be learning doesn't mean you have to be
writing you have to be doing
experiencing different things I think
different perspectives there's an
spective so even though you have a great
jiu-jitsu teacher in the and the Gracie
brothers yeah
you know what I'm gonna hang out we
could bring you four shots yeah when you
see my back rip I pull myself up like a
champ like a champ through 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift